[Music]
yes yes has anybody ever explain to you
what's being said how are you has
anybody ever explain to you what goes on
the moss with the dyeing your hearing
means some of it yeah I know some yeah
share with me what you know
I know about the Imam there sits
particularly then you know what he's
with it with their Don just the Dom it
started walk with Allahu Akbar Allahu
Akbar which means God is the greatest
God is the greatest
the veneks says a shadow and that
declaration of that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the Creator and
there become law yes then I bear what's
the Shahada this is how much someone is
because in this event this is Islam this
is the whole teachings right there
there's some duck so then the testimony
goes as follows that there's nothing
worthy of worship except the crater and
I bear witness that Muhammad is the
messenger yes now if you didn't know
this that when you justify that Muhammad
is the messenger the last message is
sent by God you automatically include
Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
preceding vessels because guess what
they came they came with Islam and this
is what we practice in Islam
you know what Islam means yes what
they'll call you Tommy
Islam is to submit your will out yes to
the creator of and this is how you
achieve peace right so you have the five
pillars then you have now the first
pillar we just discussed the pure
monotheism of declaring first and
negation you're saying look I'm not
gonna worship Jesus it's not gonna
worship the money in my pocket I'm not
sure workers just stick a stone about
nothing other than the one who created
me makes sense yes I just goes with our
nature and then now if I testify that
like if you guys did that right now
you'd be considered Muslim that's not
simple and easy it is then you'd say ok
now you got to fulfill because talk is
cheap you got to fulfill those action
this with the pillars praying five times
a day giving in the charity yes fasting
during the month of Ramadan
and then you're there versus you to you
know the african-americans Muhammad Ali
the Malcolm X you have the transatlantic
that came over this in just as a habitat
african-american the majority of those
that were brought unjustly to the
Americas for Muslims yes submit to the
will of God
you guys ready to come back to your
roots very interesting do you agree with
the things I'm sure I'm clean with what
you've said yes now let me add one more
thing if you guys come from a Christian
background I've become professional did
you did you know that Islam is the only
non Christian faith which makes it an
article of faith because there's a six
article of faith and faith in there that
you believe in the messengers to believe
as Jesus is one of the mightiest
messengers ever sent if you deny Jesus
you don't buy yourself a one-way ticket
to the Hellfire doctor so you have to
honor him not as a god or as a literal
son of God but as a Messenger of God
that he came with the same message as
Abraham Moses Jesus Mohammed worship
only one God
here o Israel as the Bible said the Lord
thy God is one that's that's the
universal way of life from the beginning
the first man Adam all the messengers
until the last message of Prophet
Muhammad and then he came with the
evidence the Quran so anybody who
sincere with genuine looks at the Quran
because I can make these claims everyone
can make claims but now you put it to
the test and you read it open it up you
say hold on there's no way this will
come from human David right
and then you end up yes so I know about
him going out into the desert and
Jibril Gabriel who's giving him the word
same angellist is that God Almighty
communicated to the other prophets the
same thing from here yeah he would
seclude himself the people used to
worship idols right yes so then from
there the message came to him and then
he came out to the people and deliver
that message for so what we have now
because one we have a believable message
like when I talked about I'm not time i
worshipping statues or aliens or flying
monsters what time I worship being the
one who created us then from there now
we look at the Quran we look at the
miracle of the crime how it's been
preserved over 23 years we have it now
you can have a translation in Bosnian
and Spanish and English but the original
is in the Arabic so now when you look at
the preservation of the crown when you
look at the things the prophecies that
are mentioned in there when you look at
the facts not fiction in there of the
human development of the embryo and
other facts that there's no way that
this human being does better when of the
desert could have known these things and
then other predictions that from his
life that he had prophesized and you're
like hold on leaving the message this
book could not have come from him or
group Amman now you're left with no
other alternative but to either turn
away or to submit to Allah God told us
to do yeah
so I can you tell me about the the type
of Islam that was practicing in this
area in here uses the sutras in the
realm so it in here yes approach your
clinic your support you okay yeah okay
so what you have here is you have the
Orthodox following because God Almighty
when he sent the crowd then you have the
Prophet Muhammad same thing as during
the time of Jesus if you're living
during a time of Jesus you'd have to not
go ahead and jump over his teachings you
had to go now worship Him but believe in
the message he came in he came with the
NGO and he was a walking instruction
manual to that same thing during a time
of Moses the Torah he came with the
Torah and then he was explaining that
now you have problem ahamed they came
with the Quran and his Sunna his example
so those who follow his Sunna they was
lay with them soon these followers of
the Sunnah to follow me so this is what
you have here so have you got Ike see
you know some crying others yes it's
very nice to see you guys here also yeah
but we've traveled we traveled a lot in
Turkey yeah we traveled a lot in Turkey
in Turkey and we've also been around an
Albanian you guys are like family
already like you know I'm very
passionate about sharing the message
there's a lot of misconceptions about
Islam yes yes and and and what we try to
do is you know through my program clear
the misconceptions deliver the message
share it there's no coercion you can't
force them on but but we've seen so many
people studying Islam but they have
never been invited
so we also let people know that at
anytime anyone this is not a way of life
that's exclusive to their border Bosnia
this is for you for you for everyone
else good so at any time if someone
feels like look I just want to connect
with my Creator I believe Muhammad is
the messenger as shadow and you know
hail allah wa ashadu anna muhammadan
rasul allah that's the Shahada yes
nothing worthy of worship like that then
we started with that I declared it
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one who created me the creator of
the heavens and earth and era in Arabic
Allah Aramaic language Jesus spoke he
would say Aloha
hello Elohim right yes and now I'm gonna
live according to God's will not my
desires you're a Muslim and you take
those baby steps you start learning and
learning growing implementing as much as
you can and then when you make a mistake
you turn to God the most merciful the
most loving and you keep moving forward
rid of me like you get off you fall off
the bike but you get right back on
I think the prayers gonna start I know I
would have gone in but I don't have go
in walk through if you guys are still
around if your questions I'll answer I'm
gonna go pray what's your name thank you
Gary yeah nice meeting you this would be
like nice meeting you